I think everybody can make a mistake and
I think
I think in my honest opinion
I think how I how I think of living my
life I'm crying for real okay Will Smith
in tears recalling the moment he slapped
Chris Rock at the 2022 Oscars
oh wow the actor appeared on Mondays The
Daily Show with Trevor Noah his first
late night appearance since the slap
heard round the world will who says he
flew 30 hours to be there opened up
about the infamous incident that was a
horrific night as you can imagine
um
you know there's many nuances and and
complexities to it you know
um
but at the end of the day I just I lost
it I guess the thing that was most
painful for me is
I took my heart and made it hard for
other people you'll remember will slap
Chris after he made a joke about his
wife Jada Pinkett Smith's shaved head a
joke that didn't go over well with the
actress who's made it publicly known she
struggles with alopecia a hair loss
disorder and looking back at his own
past will says everything just boiled up
in that moment it was a lot of things it
was the the little boy that watched his
father beat up his mother you know it's
you know all of that just bubbled up
yeah yeah in in in that moment
um
you know I just
that's not who I want to be and as Noah
offered his support that's when things
got emotional I think it's not who you
are I think everybody can make a mistake
and I think
I think in my honest opinion I think how
I how I think of living my life now I'm
crying for real okay but the hardest
thing for will seeing how the slap
impacted his family my nephew Dom is
nine and he is the sweetest little boy
he's like you know we came home and it's
like he had stayed up late to see his
uncle will you know and we're sitting in
my kitchen and he's on my lap and he's
holding the Oscar
and he's just like
why did you hit that man Uncle will
you know damn it yeah yeah why are you
trying to Oprah me
it was a mess you know I don't want to
go too far into it Will's been in and
out of the spotlight since the Oscars
and back in July he released this video
apologizing on camera I've reached out
to
Chris
um and the mesh the message that came
back is that uh he's not ready to talk
and when he is he will reach out
um
so I will I will say to you uh
Chris I
apologize to you my behavior was
unacceptable
and I'm here whenever you're ready to
talk for Jada and I have you know we
weathered some storms and for will to
move forward he's made the decision to
forgive himself that was one of the big
things for me over this last couple of
months you know that I had to forgive
myself for Being Human you know and it's
like
trust me there's nobody that hates the
fact that I'm human more than me
[Music]